MINHAZ KAZI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our session on
building a petabyte scale
reporting pipeline on GCP.
I'm Minhaz Kazi, a developer
advocate at Google,
and I'll be joined
by Michael Wallman.
Michael is an Infrastructure
Lead at Google Cloud platform.
In this presentation,
we'll be talking
about how GCP and
Waze collaborated
to implement a solution for
a petabyte scale reporting
platform.
We'll also show how
this project aligns
with the vision for our
analytics program, the database
management and analytics
vision on the slide.
And as you can see, we focus
a lot on an open philosophy.
We want to deliver
flexible features
and apply intelligent
Google technologies
to help our customers.
For the presentation, we'll
be talking about business
requirements and challenges
that this project had,
and then we'll also talk about
the technical architectures
and data pipelines.
Finally, we'll talk about
the connector we created
and then the dashboard
solution we came up with,
and the outcomes.
But first, here's
Tommy Hunt from Waze,
who will be talking about
the business requirements
and challenges.
TOMMY HUNT: Thank you.
My name is Tommy Hunt, and
I'm an analyst at Waze.
Many of you may be
familiar with Waze
as a crowdsource navigation
app that helps get you
from place to place.
We have over 130 million
monthly active users
across 185 countries that
collectively completed over one
billion navigations in 2019.
Our partners and users reported
over 60 million traffic
incidents each
month, and our map
is maintained by 30,000
volunteer map editors.
Best of all, Waze is completely
free for anybody to use.
Under the hood, Waze is
even bigger than that.
We're a mobility
platform that helps
people move more freely
in the communities
where they live and work.
Just as we give users access
to real-time information
within the app, we also partner
with over 1,300 cities, towns,
and non-profit organizations
to share that data
through a program we
call Waze for Cities,
helping to inform their mobility
strategies and their responses.
In fact, we currently help with
more than 60 crises each year,
such as hurricanes
and earthquakes,
and we're helping cities
get safer through beacons
by giving drivers a way to stay
connected even when they're out
of range of GPS.
And our newest
initiative, Waze Carpool,
is helping to combat the
rising congestion in cities
around the world.
Our city partnerships and
community-driven approach
is what makes Waze
unique and sets us apart
from other navigation apps.
If you're interested in
learning more about Waze
or if you're interested in
becoming a Waze for Cities
partner, visit
Waze.com/WazeForCities.
Now, through our Waze
for Cities program,
we offer a variety of
tools and offerings, which
include data sharing, carpool,
beacons, and crisis mitigation.
Today we're going to focus on
how Google Cloud has helped
us improve one of these
offerings, the data
that we share with partners.
Through our data
sharing offering,
Waze provides real-time
proprietary incident
and slowdown
information generated
by millions of Waze drivers
to inform our partners'
mobility strategies.
The data we share includes
user-generated reports
like traffic jams, crashes,
constructions, and potholes,
just to name a few.
Now before we began
working with Google Cloud,
Waze data was shared with our
city partners via a GeoRSS feed
in JSON and XML formats.
Partners had to take a lot of
steps to begin using this data.
These steps included ingesting,
storing, and then paying
for the ongoing storage
of this Waze data,
among several other
technical details.
Needless to say, it was
really difficult for many
of our resource-strapped
city partners
to consider this
process, which really
limited most of our partners'
ability to use our data at all.
So that's why we
turned to Google Cloud
to find a way to
manage and share
this data with our partners
in a simpler and overall more
cost-effective way.
Now I'll turn it over to
my colleague, Michael,
to talk about the technical
implementation of this tool.
MICHAEL WALLMAN: OK.
Hi.
So, starting with the Waze
and Google Cloud platform
integration, so
obviously BigQuery--
we started with BigQuery in
combination with Data Studio
was the platform or
the services of choice.
OK.
Challenges.
So first, we needed to ingest
data from an outside source.
So Waze provided
us an API to hit,
and we used that API to pull in
all the world's traffic data.
Another challenge
is that the system
had to support thousands
of partners at once.
So there was no telling when
partners were using the system
or making queries,
so therefore we
had to assume that there'd
be a lot of concurrency
in the thousands.
Simple user-aware dashboards,
meaning that if I'm a partner
and I go to a
dashboard, I would like
to see the data
that's relevant to me,
whereas another partner
should see the data that's
relevant to them without
moving around or having
to set that on every login.
So that was really important.
Another challenge would be,
if I were to make changes
to the default
dashboards, they should
propagate for all partners.
So I didn't want to have to edit
or have individual dashboards
per partner.
It was a requester
does not pay model,
meaning that partners are
not charged for this service,
and that Google or
Waze, in this case
is providing the
service for free.
And then one of the
major challenges,
which wasn't technical, is that
it was a small development team
with little to no SRE support.
OK.
Before I go into details on
the technical architecture,
I want to call out a
teammate, Egan [? Suarez, ?]
from our lab tech
customer engineering
team, who really helped design
and develop these pipelines.
I myself worked with Egan,
but also mainly focused
on the connector and the
dashboard development.
So number one, we had
our data pipelines.
So we ingested the world's
traffic data, in essence,
into BigQuery.
Number two, user management.
Partners onboarded to the system
through a simple web portal.
And then number three, they
go to a default dashboard.
They get access to the data
that's of interest to them.
And number four is how to
use the partner's behavior,
or how the partners are
accessing the data, to make
judgments on what data is
valuable to our partners
and what dashboards are
they really finding value
in so we can modify the
dashboards accordingly.
OK.
The data pipeline.
We used App Engine Flex and
its Chrome functionality
to stream data in from
Waze's traffic API
into BigQuery partition tables.
And so Cron would
run periodically,
and we would basically
query that API
and pull in all the data for
that period since the last run,
and write it into
partition tables.
And then, from these
partition tables,
we set up BigQuery
scheduled jobs.
And so what they would do is
they would transform and dedupe
the data writing into
cluster tables in BigQuery.
OK.
User management.
The user management
consisted of partners
logging into a web portal
and selecting the polygons
they were interested in.
And this gets written into
a partner table in BigQuery.
We chose to use BigQuery
because, just for simplicity--
this is a very small
table so it doesn't really
fit the BigQuery use case,
but for simplicity we
just decided to keep the
user information in BigQuery
as well.
So following a similar
pattern as the data pipelines,
we have an App Engine job that
uses Cron to run periodically.
It looks at the partner
table, and based
on changes, whether a partner
gets added or removed,
it creates authorized views
for these partners in BigQuery.
Now as you see from
the diagram, there's
something called
intermediate views.
And we had to add
these to work around
the 2,500 limit of
authorized use per data set.
So, in essence, we have
created views of views.
And intermediate views
basically use an ASCII regex
to [? doc-route ?] partners in
different intermediate views.
And this allowed us to
get over that 2,500 limit.
And now Minhaz is this
going to cover the reporting
requirements.
MINHAZ KAZI: Thank you, Michael.
So stemming from the
technical challenges we had,
we determined what the
requirements for the reporting
would be.
First we'll set the
data for separate cities
were in separate data sets.
It would have to be accessed
from separate data sets.
And there we'd have
to ensure data privacy
because we didn't want
any of the partners
to see other partner's data.
So if they were looking
at a dashboard or any kind
of reporting solution,
they would only
be able to see their own city's
data and not anyone else's one.
There was also the requirement
for the centralized billing
to have that frictionless user
experience because, since we
didn't want the city's
partners to carry
the bill for this
dashboard, the billing would
be managed centrally by
the Waze and GCP team.
So there would be a
central billing account
that would be taking care
of the BigQuery querying
through the dashboard.
There would also have to
be a single point of change
for all the dashboard edits.
That means if a future change
was made to the dashboard
or if any kind of
update was to be made,
it would have to get
rolled out to all
the partners at the same time.
So there would have to be some
kind of an easy deployment
system for that.
And based on these requirements,
we decided to use Data Studio.
Data Studio is a data
visualization and reporting
tool that's available freely
from Google Marketing platform.
And it works very
well with BigQuery.
It has a native
connector to BigQuery.
If you're using BigQuery
data in Data Studio
you can use the PI
engine to take advantage
of its fast in-memory
calculations
and get very speedy results.
So as the team was looking
into this solution,
we realized that there were
several alternatives available.
First was using the
native connector
to create a single dashboard
with viewer screenshots.
What viewer screenshots
mean is that when someone
would view the dashboard,
their credentials
would get passed
through Data Studio
into the data source, which
here would be BigQuery.
And then that
credentials would be
used to enforce what data
they would get to see.
And here would be using
role level access,
either through Date Studio's
email-based filtering
or BigQuery's [INAUDIBLE]
user function.
But the limitation here
was that, if we wanted
to use either of
those two features,
we'd have to march
all those data
sets into one single
table or source
and then filter
from there, which
became a little bit
complicated, because there
were over 1,400 partners.
The second option was to use,
again, the native connector,
but there we would create
one template dashboard
and then copy over the
dashboard multiple times,
one time for each
partner, and then
edit the data source so that it
would point to the right data
set.
That had its own
challenges because it
would be possible to
copy over the dashboards,
but if we wanted to
make any future changes
or wanted to do maintenance,
doing it over 1,400
different dashboards would
become near impossible.
So we opted for the
third solution, which
was the custom
connector, and we'll
go into that in
more details later.
But what the custom
connector would do
is it would make a
customized solution involving
Data Studio and BigQuery.
It would meet all the
reporting requirements
that I just mentioned
earlier, and this
would record any minimum
level of development
from the team that
was working on it.
The custom connectors are built
on the Community Connector
platform for Data Studio.
These are written
in App Script, which
is Google's cloud-based
serverless scripting engine.
And it takes a very
low amount of effort
to build connectors
using this framework.
Anyone can build a connector.
You can connect to any
external data sources
and pull in the data
into a Data Studio.
And it's also possible to share
and publish those connectors
so that others can use.
If you are interested
in learning more
about these connectors,
you can check out
the Codelab we have at
this URL on the screen.
The Community Connector is
already an established program
where there are over 200
published connectors available.
And here at Google we ourselves
have used this platform
to create several connectors
to serve data to the public.
For example, the
ChromeUX Connector
uses this connector platform
to serve ChromeUX report data
to users.
So it was already a
proven solution for us.
However, one thing we have
never tried with these solutions
was that we didn't implement
the user-based view
in any of these connectors.
So what that means is,
in user-based view,
multiple users will look
at the same dashboard,
but based on their
credentials, who they are,
it would fetch data from
different data sets, which
is a bit different from
roll over access, because we
are accessing completely
different data sets.
And then the dashboard would
get populated with data
from those data sets.
So this was something
new that the team
was trying out with the
Community Connector approach.
And our end result
would look something
similar to this, that
the connector would
get created, and using
that connector we'd create
a dashboard, a single
dashboard link, and that
would be sent to all the
1,400 different partners.
When a partner opens
their dashboard link,
they will see their dashboard
with their own data,
and they wouldn't have
any flexibility or option
to switch over to see a
separate user's dashboard.
So this is a complete user
experience we wanted to have.
A user gets a
link, clicks on it,
they immediately
view their report.
So to do this under
the hood, this
is what we had to implement.
So once the user clicks
on the dashboard link,
it opens up the Data
Studio dashboard.
And Data Studio will then
execute the connector
with viewer screenshots.
The first time any user
opens this dashboard,
they will have to go through
an authorization flow
where they authorize
this connector
to run on their behalf.
But this is done only for
the first time they use it.
For all subsequent
times, the dashboard
will open up automatically.
So Data Studio executes
the connector script,
and the connector script then
takes the user's credentials
and figures out,
all right, this is
the email for this user
who's viewing the dashboard.
And then it makes a call
to the BigQuery REST API
to figure out which data set
should this user be viewing.
So we had a mapping table
that mapped each user's email
address with a specific
list of data sets.
So this REST API call enabled
us to query into BigQuery
and get the result
back where we would
say, all right, this
email address, x, has
access to data set y.
So once this information
was back in the connector,
we'd then construct a new query.
And this query
string would contain,
basically this data set
idea that we just fetched.
So it would say something
like, select [? App Script ?]
from data set y.
But we would not send this
query off to BigQuery directly.
What we would do is
that then the connector
would use the Data
Studio at-home services
to make the query
directly into BigQuery.
So let's then look a bit deeper
into that, what that means.
To communicate
between Data Studio
and BigQuery the native
connector directly works.
But when you are working
with a community connector,
the data will usually have
to pass through App Script,
and it will have to be
transformed and processed
in App Script which
adds a bit of overhead
in calculation and latency.
Using Advance Services for
Data Studio, what we can do is,
rather than passing the
data through App Script,
we can just pass the query
itself to Data Studio,
and the Data Studio will pass
that query to BigQuery directly
and fetch the data from BigQuery
using a native connection.
The data does not pass
through App Script in any way,
so it results in a much
faster interaction.
All the features are
ultimately pushed down,
and then the users also get a
much better, faster dashboard
experience.
So finally, Data Studio
passes that query
into BigQuery, which is the
final query for the dashboard,
which contains only the data
set that this user has access
to see.
And finally, the results
are sent back to Data Studio
and Data Studio renders
that data in dashboard,
and the viewer finally
can see their dashboard
with their own data.
So since in the
return queries results
step, only the user's
data set is passed,
there is no way for a different
user to see that data set
or for this user to see data
from a different data set.
So what does the end
result look like?
This is the whole process,
but when the user finally
opens the dashboard,
they get a view
that looks something like this.
This is the view that all
the users-- all the 1,400
different partner-- see.
When they open the dashboard,
they get a dashboard like this.
At the top there are filters.
They can change the filters.
They can interact with
it and this dashboard
will interactively present
the data for whatever features
or selections they're making.
Each partner would
see only their view
and they wouldn't
see anything else.
And based on this
dashboard, the team
made some further
improvements where
they added for their pages.
They also added some
monitoring where
they could measure how the
dashboard was being used
through Stackdriver, which
partners were using it,
which partners were incurring
additional data costs.
It's also possible to set
up data limits by partner.
So a feature would
potentially work
is where we could potentially
take this solution
and then build in limits where
each partner would get, say,
a certain amount of limit.
If they hit that
limit every month,
then their dashboard
wouldn't become visible.
Another potential
solution that can
be implemented on
top of this is,
using Google Analytics
for Data Studio,
it can be measured
how the users are
interacting with the dashboard.
Which pages are they looking at?
Which places are they
spending the most time on?
And then make the dashboard
much better and faster and more
usable for users that way.
If anyone wants to build
a similar solution using
Data Studio, Advance
Services, and BigQuery,
these links would be helpful.
The first link basically
provides a step
by step guide on how to build
a connector similar to this.
And the second link
contains a code example
of a similar connector.
You can just take
the code example
and customize it
to your own needs.
So what finally happened
after this project?
This project was
launched in October 2019.
After launch, there were
numerous positive news stories.
Over 200 news stories were
published on Digital Trends
and Venture Beats.
Right now over 6,000 users
from more than 1,400 partners
across the world are using
this dashboard every day.
And as Michael
mentioned earlier,
the connector that he created
and the dashboard that he came
up with, it's working basically
in a [? no-ops ?] fashion,
even with such high
amount of usage.
And there are over 30,000
accesses of the Data Studio
dashboard, and more
than 800,000 queries
have been made in BigQuery
by all these partners.
Now this was a
major collaboration
between Waze and
Google Cloud, and Waze
plans to continue to
promote the data tools
and build education
materials to aid traffic
planning across the world.
And that brings us to the
end of our presentation.
Thank you.